[Música]
pero está bien
hola hola
soy may ball tengo 22 años soy
originaria de nashville tennessee si van
a la derecha de maywood se quedarán si
van hacia la izquierda saldrán del
escenario y tomarán asiento
listos ya
sin resentimiento
por quedarse
[Música]
si no está abrir las botellas de
champaña me asustan mucho la brujita la
un poco
cuando me detengo linda de que te
gradúas de comunicación social
trabajan estrategias para influyentes
qué edad tienen 20 21 21 21 22
suficiente
muy bien me gustan los museos me gusta
el arte muy bien me un librito sobre la
música qué música te gustó y gustó brock
hampton pero escucho a otros artistas me
gusta el pop adolescente me gusta cuando
direction me encanta y si no les gusta
deberían ir me encanta
me gusta
tengo un tocadiscos y música de jazz
tengo un disco de luismi
él es genial me encanta en la secundaria
llegaba temprano a la escuela era una
nerd y me sentaba a escuchar música de
jazz si tenía un examen o algo así
volvía al planeta diciendo 'vamos may
von háblanos sobre tu estilo de vestir
debes ser elegante con las fotos y la
chaqueta me gustó mucho es genial el año
pasado detecte mi ropa porque fui a una
escuela sureña donde había chicas de la
hermandad lo cual no era mi estilo
entonces cuando dejé esa burbuja pensé
bien necesito encontrar algunas prendas
de vestir así que busque un estilo más
atrevido fabuló el negro me gusta el
cuero me gustan los patinadores esa
cultura y lo que esa cultura hace por la
comunidad esa fue una buena pregunta
gracias alguna locura en la universidad
mi amiga y yo nos quedamos despiertas
hasta las 7 de la mañana porque
queríamos esperarlos biscuits de pollo
de mcdonald que aquí no tienen pero para
mi sorpresa fue de maceración de pollo
panecillo ambas nos quedamos dormidas
comiendo los biscuits de pollas que
vivió en tus relaciones anteriores de
cuál es lo mejor de tu personalidad que
aprendí de mis relaciones y claro creo
que aprendí a ser independiente los
chicos con los que estuve me enseñaron
que no podía contar con ellos pero no
fue nada malo porque así pude entender
que solo puedo contar conmigo misma dejé
de salir con chicos por un año ahora
sólo estoy pensando bien quiero ser
independiente pero también quiero que
alguien sea independiente conmigo si
quiero viajar por el mundo
con dependencia es como un nacimiento
que deberían ser independientes juntos
podemos salir juntos pero también tengo
a mis amigos si no me necesitas y
viceversa así y así es es mirar yo
artificio
ryan y may ball que lo que hiciste
cortar así que
creo que hay una conexión pensé en
realidad voy a perder así que me la tomé
con champaña alguna locura en la
universidad viví muchas cosas locas en
una escuela sureña y yo creo que es
ricky ellos tienen una colección musical
bueno saben bien con el jazz pues yo
solo paso al que está a mi derecha si
ella se sale contigo yo lo haré yo
vamos a ver
podías escribir lo más pequeño y lo
pusiste de este tamaño
que escribiste la letra antes de
escribirlo
[Música]
i
y el concursante que ha sido eliminado
es
álex
lo lamento amigos nos vemos yo no hable
mucho así que está bien
[Música]
hola cómo estás estoy muy bien te daré
la mano estrechas la mano me gustan tus
anillos es una experiencia surrealista
cómo estás nervioso ansioso e
hipnotizado
estuviste en una fraternidad si
bien yo quisiera saber cuál es tu mejor
halago genial primero halagaría tu
atuendo me gusta tu ropa en realidad me
gusta el cordón de la cintura si hoy no
tenía cinturón
no eres
no te agradó mucho yo soy géminis
yo nunca sería así no diría no salgo
contigo porque eres géminis excepto con
acuario no sé si sentarme sabes que soy
de acuario
lo siento lo siento quisiera decirte que
también me gusta como
en realidad yo misma
podrías ayudar si te entiendo te ayuda
gracias puedo ver tu lo dice lo suyo mis
uñas yo misma las pinte no
esperen algo sencillas pero gracias a
estas reglas también tienes alguna meta
como profesión como dije trabajo en
estrategias para influyentes ya que hay
un gran futuro en las redes sociales
aunque siento que aún hay personas que
las menosprecian hay muchos que son
influyentes pero que hacen mucho daño
aunque también hay muchos que son
seguidores son personas increíbles y sin
duda buenos recurso que es maravilloso
sé que estás tratando de difundir algo
positivo y estoy de acuerdo con ella
planeas hacer al graduar te quiero
ingresar al programa de cadetes para
hacer bombero al estar allí trabajaré
para lograr mis metas me ofrecí para
ayudar a rehabilitar lobos marinos y yo
amo a los animales cuando era más joven
quería ser veterinaria y estar con ánimo
todo el tiempo yo quiero dejar la carne
porque amo a los animales
yo fui dos años vegetariana en la
secundaria y un documental que se
llamaba si los mataderos tuvieran
paredes de cristal y quedé traumatizada
entonces rechacé la carne roja y luego
comí sandy este pollo y luego dije
extraño la carne pero me encantaría ser
vegana conozco un lugar vegano muy bueno
donde tienen tacos y burritos veganos
around y si suena un lugar ideal es el
mejor lugar para una primera muy bien a
donde te gusta ir más me encanta el cine
y a mi padre le encantaría sí qué
película te gustan todas las de leonardo
dicaprio
me encanta con dios la lana es muy bueno
sobre todo el jazz a ti me gustaría me
gustaria yo soy tocar algunas canciones
no me podría dar unos elena funk y
cuando sería la edad adecuada para tener
un hijo mis padres se casaron como a los
28 quiero disfrutar mi vida luego
conseguir un compañero viajar juntos y
después casarme formar una familia como
a los 30 cuantos quiero estar en 3
una buena cantidad si bien gracias un
placer hablar contigo gracias por la
charla soy bien y claro fue todo es 20
eres un encanto gracias
[Risas]
sabes que la seducía por detrás pero
hizo la mayor parte del tiempo por todos
los diablos que dije
así que yo digo pensamiento mágico que
tiene me toca a mí
[Música]
sientes que los chicos han acertado con
lo que sientes tomarán la decisión
correcta todos me parecen muy auténticos
entonces confío en ellos 1 2 y 3
y
te daré un abrazo hola
cómo te sientes de verdad me siento muy
feliz con el resultado yo también estoy
muy feliz eres muy dulce y me gusta
hablar contigo así que
si él es increíble
está bien ahora les mostraremos cuál fue
la elección de maywood
ahí lo tienes
ahora vinos a quien había elegido en la
segunda ronda en la segunda ronda bien
elegí a jeter
[Risas]
y aquí en elegiste en la tercera ronda
que ver
solo porque me gusta su estilo y además
tuvimos una buena conversación pero
también me gustaría intercambiar números
contigo esto bueno ya concretando las
cosas con los dos me sentí muy bien
charlando así que funcionó perfectamente
creo yo
crees que se seguirán viendo después de
esto hablas de los tres
por separado sí claro cómo se sienten
chicos me siento bien si no era él tenía
que ser yo
realmente yo voté por él yo también voté
por él
para nosotros ha sido todo
muy bien
sí muchas gracias por venir may ball
para nosotros ha sido todo un placer
para mí también gracias
y muchas gracias a ustedes chicos